you're looking for a cool place to cool
off read a book and get some business
work done well the renovated green
valley library is a new option and you
don't even have to buy a nine dollar
coffee
to get some wi-fi i'm sure they do the
library will feature a career hub and a
business hub operating side by side we
have mary jane bellies joining us live
with the details this morning
well heather and john we're talking
about libraries reimagined and the green
valley library has expanded and
reinvented their space to include a
career hub here i'm actually joined with
megan jordan from nv employee career hub
and you know this is a great place to
really have people in the community kind
of enjoy a space where they can get help
with job opportunities and job options
yes absolutely we did have a small hub
here at green valley
recently and we just felt like we needed
to expand so now we have this amazing
space for employee and seeking
job interviews
seeking resume building skills we have
dedicated staff that spoke that speak
both english and spanish to better serve
our community and we can help with
interview skills we can connect with job
trainings we are just looking forward to
working with people who are interested
in getting involved in our society
helping others whatever your interest is
we can connect you we're really excited
about that and what's really cool is
this is all free as well no charge at
all at no cost you can come in here
please come in here and take our surveys
that we have find out what you're
interested in you know kovid we got a
lot of time by ourselves to really think
about what our interests and
things that we would like to do come in
here and share that with us we have
dedicated staff we have a beautiful
beautiful space confidential spaces
we have different types of computer labs
we can sit down and talk to you and make
that dream into a reality
and you mentioned that uh you know this
is kind of an expansion and this isn't
the first one the first one was actually
in the sahara west so just having this
extension just really talks about what
the community needs are and fulfilling
that need absolutely we like to meet
people where they are not where we
expect them to be and so by expanding
our locations 100 percent we're meeting
the community so we just really are
excited to also offer employers
over on our other side here so when you
come in here you can meet with employers
job seeking you can do career coaching i
mean just be a part of our system
perfect well megan thank you so much for
joining us this morning and the
community is also invited to check out
the library at 3 p.m civic leaders and
other community members will also be
here in attendance and you're invited to
come free of cost reporting live in
henderson mary jane balleza live local
now